entender el universo y nuestro lugar en
el es la misión del telescopio espacial
james webb diseñado para observar más
lejos que nunca me gusta pensar en él
como el vehículo de la nasa para la
exploración espacial más profunda que la
nasa puede hacer nos permitirá ver más
atrás en el tiempo hasta el momento en
que nacieron las primeras estrellas o de
la acción 6 el telescopio bautizado así
en honor al ex director de la nasa será
llevado al espacio en el cohete europeo
ariane-5 que lo liberará tras un viaje
de 26 minutos al mirar en el infrarrojo
el telescopio podrá ver moléculas
alrededor de estrellas jóvenes que aún
se están formando también podremos ver
atmósferas de planetas alrededor de
otras estrellas observaremos cientos de
ellas y podremos ver moléculas basadas
en carbono que son importantes para la
vida y también indican la química y sólo
la composición general de estas
atmósferas que no conocemos ahora
originalmente el telescopio debía estar
en el espacio hace más de una década
pero su lanzamiento ha sufrido
innumerables retrasos la pandemia y
problemas técnicos causaron que no
pudiera ponerse en órbita hace siete
meses más reciente fue debido al el
tiempo en el sitio de lanzamiento en la
guyana francesa finalmente despega esta
navidad para responder preguntas como
cómo llegamos hasta aquí que tan único
es nuestro planeta y estamos solos en el
universo